all right it's inspired by tua since
he's the new starter down there since
dan
marino retired after the 1999 season
what dolphins qb
has the highest winning percentage as a
starter
gosh so this could be a guy who just
started two games and won both of them i
doubt it okay i doubt he would do that
to you it's probably something like five
games yeah
okay i'll just go with the least obvious
but the guy who was the successor to dan
marino go with jay fiedler yeah good
guess way to go hey
i didn't even look down there it is
right there 36 and 23 and made the
playoffs yeah see the thing is
you could still be adequate after
mourinho
but you're not mourinho it still feels
like a huge drop off the huge drop off
didn't come until after jay fiedler so
all right i get the first pick then in
this draft of who's out of the trust
tree players coaches teams we no longer
have faith in hmm where am i going to
start here
uh the entire minnesota vikings
organization you're out of the trustee
i've annulled my relationship the
paperwork has been filed we're going to
the judge in a couple of weeks sorry
it's over it's done
they've built on what they did last year
by going completely into the crapper
and it's scholarship year get out all
those contracts everybody's got a buffer
everybody's fine for this year next year
it's going to be different next year
we're going to be focused next year
we're going to win these games and
ultimately it comes down to kirk cousins
plain and simple
uh you know i'm kind of taking them both
in one it's specifically cousins it's
more broadly the team they had one more
year left and they could have gotten
away from him and tried to rebuild the
quarterback position he's got clear
limitations that aren't going to change
he can run the play that's called he
can't improvise when the play that's
called falls apart he doesn't have the
skills and ability to run away from
pressure and it's it's too much to
expect it to work all the way to a
championship you need a quarterback who
can make chicken salad out of the other
stuff on a play that falls apart if you
want to be among the best teams in the
nfl the vikings don't have that either
have a quarterback who can do that or
you don't and they should be looking for
a guy who can do it not renewing their
vows with a guy who can't period sorry
sometimes the truth hurts it hurts me
more than it hurts you kirk cousins and
the vikings yeah i mean i i get what
you're saying i know they're out of your
trust tree there too to me the decision
with kirk cousins is you know either get
a high-flying offensive coordinator who
can really take advantage of what he has
to offer because
yes they're kind of asking him to play a
game like you're talking about and
that's not what he is no it's not so
that that that to me is the issue there
and i understand you kicking them out of
the trust tree i'm going to go a
specific player i'm going to put baker
mayfield out of my trust 3. all right i
am you know again not to say they can't
win games and still and do those things
at the at with him at quarterback but
i'm certainly not trusting him to do
anything big in a big moment of a
football game or hey we're going to
start off the game and we're going to
let baker in the pass game carry us and
let us get going that way no he's out of
the trust you can't trust him with the
ball that way it's every week there's a
handful of plays throws whatever it is
of just carelessness to where he is he
teeters on losing games for the team
that time did last week so that that
will be uh for my my first draft pick
there baker mayfield out of my trust
tree
yeah i'm with you there and and there is
just this weird thing when the games
aren't going well for baker mayfield he
just doesn't look like an nfl
quarterback he doesn't it's just there's
there's just something about the way he
moves the way he's built the way he is
in his pads it doesn't look like a
quarterback and doesn't play like a
quarterback when he's having days like
that and i'm going to stay in that same
vein because remember earlier in this
year we're having the debate
is
gardner minshew the poor man's baker
mayfield or is baker mayfield now the
poor man's gardener minshu
well they're both out of the trust tree
because
i don't care how you got there i don't
care how it happened you can't go from
1-0
to 1-5
and expect to be a team that anyone is
going to take seriously and a
quarterback that's going to have a
bright future in the nfl because
franchise quarterbacks have to win games
and that they they had the potential to
beat the cult something's gone wrong
with the jaguars and i don't know why
anybody
really seems to not be all that bothered
by it's just kind of like oh well
they're the jaguars so be it but i you
know minshew's the quarterback of a team
that that has become the tonic yeah for
every other bad team out there if you're
a bad team play the jaguars and you'll
turn it around yeah no i mean it's it's
it's gotten worse you know after the
first two games of the year where you
went oh okay maybe they're going to be a
little better than we think no his plays
slipped their defense is totally falling
apart um and and i'm with you i mean i
am and hey they're another one of those
teams that it's looking like is going to
be in a fight to get trevor lawrence
it's going to be the greatest fight ever
for one damn guy and as long as i can
remember because i think he is by far
like head and shoulders above anybody
else in college football coming out from
what so it's going to be really all
about him all right my next one i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go with the bill's
defense out of the trust tree bye see
you later no longer in the circle of
trust i see you
okay yeah they can't they can't depend
on their defense they can't play games
like they did the other night where they
were a little worried about getting in a
shootout and let's they got to just get
in the shootout that's what they are
their defense what not getting a
shootout to where they can get just
bludgeoned into the ground and let
somebody run for eight yards every run
it's that is over they have to totally
play through their offense and sean
mcdermott's got to get more involved in
the defensive side of the ball obviously
there's got to be something there maybe
he's given too much power to leslie
frazier whatever it is hey they tried to
get some under the radar value signings
and free agency you know we talked about
them yesterday and then none of them
have panned out they really haven't
whether it's vernon butler and mario
addison and anything like that but they
got issues on that they're out of the
trust street for me on the defensive
side
all right next one for me and this one
isn't an easy one i've got several
different ways i can go i'm going to go
with zach taylor the bengals head coach
and here's why this should be a season
of promise of optimism doesn't matter
how many games you win but you've got
joe burrow why are there so many guys
who aren't happy in cincinnati they
should all be thrilled they've got joe
barrow he's passed the smell test he
looks like a great leader he's played
well you've got geno atkins not happy
carlos dunlap not happy john ross not
happy aj green not getting it done
something's not right there and last
year you could say it was the players
when they go 2 and 14. well now you got
joe burrow and i'm starting to wonder
how long zach taylor is going to be for
the cincinnati bengals because i just
don't think it's good at all for him
that all these guys are unhappy with
their current roles with the team no and
well this is where sometimes
that's why as a new coach you want to
just flip over the roster right because
these are a lot of old guys from the
last regime and they're like i don't
want to be a part of this anymore and
i'm not happy about it one thing i'll
say get rid of them i know get rid of
him they should be i got faith in him
he's got to act he's got to act
it should be a fire sale here for the
next few weeks well what are we hanging
on for in cincinnati move on let's
change the team over trade aj green
chained to everybody else let's go all
right my last pick and i don't like how
much they're letting joe burrow get hit
that's where i'd be pissed off about
with zach taylor um i think you know
what i don't even give a damn that
they're they're they're in the playoffs
right now the dallas cowboys are out of
my trust tree they are i'm just sorry i
i still think the eagles are gonna win
the division sorry dallas and i just
don't trust anything about the
organization right now all the things
are bubbling up star players messing up
all that so sorry dallas out of the
trust tree
am i in your trust tree of course you
are
can we sit in your trust tree and play
rock scissors paper no we can i don't
play that game i play rock paper
scissors
we'll be back with more pfd live right
now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports